We multiply this first fraction by p plus 3 divided by p plus 3. The denominator
here is missing a factor of p plus 3. This is the one factor we need in order to
change our denominator into the LCD. For our second fraction we multiply by p
minus 1 divided by p minus 1. And this denominator, p minus 1 is the missing
factor we need in order to get the LCD. Now we multiply these two numerators
together and these two denominators together this gives us our new first
equivalent fraction. We do the same process for the second fraction to get this,
these two denominators may look different but they really the same. We know the
order of the factors don't matter because its multiplication. Now that the two
fractions have like denominators, we can simply add the numerators together. We
add the like terms. The p's and the constants. 1 p and 1 p would equal 2 p and
positive 3 and negative 1 would equal positive 2. Now that we're here, we should
ask ourselves, are we done? Well, we added two things in a numerator together,
so we have a new numerator entirely. We want to see if we can factor it if
possible, and it turns out we can. We can take out a 2, to have 2 times p plus
1. But this doesn't really help us. We can't cancel a factor of p plus 1 since
another factor of p plus 1 does not appear in the denominator. So the answer is
yes, we're done, and here's the addition of these two rational expressions. Now
this is some algebra.